this is a sickness
it is deviant therefore we don't want it
this is a video captured by a student at
Oakville Trafalgar High School showing a
teacher instructing the class on how to
use a saw the teacher has been
documented on several occasions with
what people describe as very large
prosthetic breasts with protruding
nipples that are clearly seen through
form-fitting clothes the teacher's
appearance has been the subject of
reports from the New York Post and
network news in the states students tell
chch that this is a constant Topic in
class the entire school like ever every
single class that I'm in the teacher is
like the topic like she it's yeah like
and obviously the teachers have no say
over it it's just I'll be walking in the
in the hallways and
I'll see her walking around it's just
it's kind of discomforting to be in a
school environment with that the Halton
District School Board says they're not
taking any action against the teacher
saying they want to create a safe
learning environment and quote ensure a
safe and inclusive environment for all
students staff and the community
that's right
that's right that's right I tried I'm
bro I tried I really
yeah I really tried I really tried you
you're the reason I laughed because I
wasn't about to laugh and then you
started laughing I tried to try I was
good I was I was good I was like I was
doing a good job I didn't want to laugh
regardless of the race age ability sex
gender identity gender expression sexual
orientation ethnicity religion cultural
observance social economic circumstances
or body type or size adding that quote
gender identity and gender expression
are protected grounds under the Ontario
Human Rights Code a statement that
students say contradicts the school's
own dress code that they have to follow
that's exactly where I was about to go
that's exactly where I was about to go
in what students in all the show nipple
not nipples but the girls I'm pretty
sure they can't wear certain types of
skirts because it's going to be too too
too revealing right then one hand above
the knee not higher right oh she was
wearing the skirt in one of the videos
it's ridiculous why she I think it
violates a dress code completely and
it's completely inappropriate the thing
is in the dress code for htsb like it
says you need to wear opaque clothing
there are pictures even of the teacher
where you can completely see her nipples
even the color of like you can see the
color you can see the shape it's
ridiculous and it's very distracting for
students it's not like a good thing for
like a 13 year old 14 year old kids to
look at and stuff so I think teachers
should have to wear a business casual
outfit
um be presentable and professional in
the workplace these are what 13 14 year
olds talking about business casuals I
tell you what when I was 13 14 I don't
know what the [ __ ] business casual was
but this is casual is why I thought my
mom made money listen this is
interesting because whatever you want to
say shout out to these kids from being
able to not only present themselves
super well on TV coherently but also to
sound far more mature and reasonable
than most of the adults involved yes
that's super impressive so first off I
always [ __ ] on young people but God damn
they doing anything shout outs to them
okay because I was not expecting all
that
so you sent me this and I didn't really
get into it no so tell me what your
thoughts are
I'm just gonna go basically on the dress
code thing
it's out man this outrageous is out
there okay
and then the the T I believe the
teachers should follow the dress code as
much as the kids if there's a dress code
it's a dress code for everybody okay not
no privilege and stuff like that you
hear me
that's what I believe I'm not gonna go
on the identity and stuff like that and
I don't know the teacher
I don't know what I don't know I don't
know
it is doing a disturbance to trans
people and it shows to me it shows a a
different light but then again
who am I
them girls didn't show them
thank you no worse so you went on the
the sensible point which is the fashion
right I'm I'm just totally gonna stop oh
you you going in you I'll go on the
other point
this is a sickness
it is deviant therefore we don't want it
why is it deviant
listen your transition that's fine okay
but there's nowhere in in the female
anatomy that I've ever seen Triple G
titties
drooping past it listen and those are
Prosthetics on top of that you lose me
you lose faster that's enough you lose
me okay you're not telling me you're
transitioning all of a sudden you gotta
walk around with a prosthetic penis
which you know extends pasture there's
literally no no school that would ever
let a teacher walk around with a
prosthetic dick
past his knee yes walking around like
this
this is a sickness
we don't want it that's that's a valid
point no that's a valid point listen you
want to bring up trans stuff if she this
person with a transitional nobody would
say nothing bro that has nothing to do
with trans stuff how about this
I don't even care if they're transplant
if this was a CIS woman walking around
with that with nipples showing and
everything I had to have the same idea
if a CIS woman was wearing like a
prosthetic whatever no you lose me that
has nothing listen and this is but this
is this is the interesting don't be
confused this is the interesting don't
be confused when it comes to a lot of
these
um new policies that they're of
inclusivity of this is the next logical
step
this is the next logical step and so I'm
not totally mad at the school board you
wanna know why because according to the
uh ideology that they're told to adopt
right which is be inclusive to
everything this is the next logical step
guys and I'm excited
I can't wait to see what kind of the
freak Show we're going to because this
is a freak Show I'm not talking about
transists this has nothing to do with
that this is just a freak Show not be
confused yeah this is a freak do not be
confused by the Allure of this no
nothing to do with trans yeah listen
listen oh listen no thing you can't you
can't be walk around but you want to
notice how they're breaking their own
rules yeah to be quote-unquote inclusive
because they're more afraid hear how
[ __ ] crazy they don't care about the
people they're actually supposed to
serve they're more afraid of what other
people who have nothing to do with the
school district think the parents are
against us the students against this the
school board doesn't care because
they're afraid of what would happen if
it came out that they were against these
so for one teacher they're willing to
violate and disrupt entire classroom
schools okay for who
for for people on Twitter
this is a sickness nothing and it needs
to be stated you have decided to abandon
the children
you are a problem we are soon going to
see children in Ontario on a World
Vision commercial children like this
I've seen too many nipples my friends it
was so big she wore her skirt above her
knees it's not even flying where is the
business
transmit the wrong decision
it's just a no for me I haven't taught
you this if I was a kid what and I don't
want to give no ideas to nobody but if I
was a kid I'd be like oh is that how we
play it yeah is is that how that's
that's what we doing
I will walk in the street with
prosthetic dead prosthetic nibs
prosthetic everything that's what we
doing it's not what we're doing but
that's what they wanted that's what we
do it that's what we're doing now
apparently that's what we're doing now
no no I woke up one day
I woke up one day I went to school and
this is what was what we were doing well
that's what we're doing we doing this I
would walk with prosthetic everything
stuff you hear absolutely listen I think
we I think the audience is gonna agree
with us this is ridiculous I don't have
to spend too much time on this but take
a walk get the [ __ ] up out of here
please get the [ __ ] up out of here and
again shout out to the kids yeah shout
out to the kids
I know a bunch of 19 year olds my day
who are half [ __ ] things they have
32. shout out to them going on 30. they
look like they make a lot of tick tock
videos with political people our whole
Pension Plan up in this big show day 13
with a 401k well we don't have that